[Music]
welcome back to Harbor unbox today we
are checking at video's new GeForce RTX
470 super and this is the first model to
be released in the new Super Series
refresh and I'll be slotting at the
previous RTX 470 MSRP so $600 us that's
pretty exciting but before we get into
it today's sponsor spot is brought to
you by ug green and their new lineup of
nexe pro series Chargers the nexo Pro
Mini offers 65 wats of fast charging
from a single port and can charge up to
three devices at once via two USB C
ports and one USB type a port or for
super fast charging the nexo pro 100 W
charger offers not only additional power
but also the ability to charge devices
such as a Mac Pro from 0 to 86% in just
60 minutes but if that's not enough the
nexe Pro 160 has you covered with
hyperfast 140 40 W charging from a
single port All ugreen nexo Pro Chargers
feature air pyra and Gan Infinity
technology to allow very impressive
charging from a very compact unit and
are compatible with all modern
smartphones tablets and laptops if you'd
like to see the rest of the nexe pro
lineup then for more information please
check the links in the video
description okay so the 470 super uses
the same ad 104 silicon as the other
4070 series products but with much more
silicon enabled when compared to the
standard 4070 there's 22% more crud cor
so just 7% less than that of the ti
model it also gets the same 48 MB L2
cache as the ti then like the 4070 and
4070 TI it uses a 192bit wide memory bus
using 12 GB of 21 GBS per second gddr 6X
memory for a bandwidth of 54 GB per
second So based on those specifications
the 4070 super should be around 20%
faster than the 4070 for the same price
so that's pretty good it does still only
have 12 GB of memory which is a bit
stiff at the $600 us price point but at
least performance overall should be much
better the improved performance should
also help the 470 super better compete
with the much cheaper radon RX 7800 XT
at least in terms of value the radon GPU
did Force Nvidia to Discount the RTX 470
to $550 and this is where it will remain
so this is an official price cut and
that does mean that the original 4070
will continue to exist coming in $50
less than the super model and Nvidia
again has noted that this is a new
official MSRP for that part I do expect
though that the RTX 470 will quickly
find itself down around $500 alongside
the 7800 XT because who's going to be
enticed to save $50 on what will be a
much slower GPU surely you just go with
the newer 4070 super model
anyway we'll take a look at the
performance and then we'll dive into the
cost per frame
analysis for testing we're using our
ryzen 7 a 7800x 3D test system with 32
GB of DDR 56000 memory using the latest
display drivers all data has been
validated and updated for this video and
I'll be using the Nvidia Founders
edition of the 4070 super in total I've
tested 12 games some with and without R
tracing and the resolutions are focused
for this review will be 1440p and 4K
okay let's take a look at what we have
first up we have a plague toil requium
and at 1440p the 470 super is offering a
16% performance bump over the standard
4070 and that's enough to make it 7%
faster than the 7800 XT and just 5%
slower than the 470
TI then at 4K we're looking at 53 FPS on
average making the 470 super just 4%
faster than the 7800 XT but again just
5% slower than the 470 TI we also
looking at a 15% uplift when compared to
the standard 4070 so a good result there
the gains in Resident Evil 4 over the
original 4070 are less impressive at
1440p here the new super variant was
just 12% faster averaging 140 FPS still
that did make it 9% faster than the 7800
XT though interestingly despite that it
was still 10% slower than the 4070
TI again the radon GPU is able to close
the gap at the 4K resolution and see the
470 super was just 4% faster than the
7800 XT and it was still 9% slower than
the 470 TI but this time 177% faster
than the original
4070 you'd probably expect the 4070
super to leave the 7800 XT behind in
cyberpunk 2077 but without rate tracing
enabled the results are highly
competitive the GeForce GPU was just 2%
faster this is a much needed boost
though for NVIDIA in this matchup given
that the 4070 super is 188 % faster than
the standard
4070 we're still looking at just a 2%
margin in favor of the 4070 super at 4K
rendering just a single extra frame over
the 7800 XT and this time we are looking
at a big 24% boost over the standard
4070 Hogwarts Legacy further
demonstrates just how need of a
performance boost in video was at the
$600 price point the 4070 super is just
3% faster than the 7800 XT at 1440p
despite offering a massive 26% increase
over the standard
4070 unfortunately though the 470 super
still slipped behind the 7800 XT at 4K
rendering 47 FPS on average making it 8%
slower oddly the 470 super was just 4%
faster than the standard 470 here though
it was also just 2% slower than the 470
TI strongly suggesting that vram
capacity is the bottleneck here for
these 4070 series
products next next up we have the new
avatar game and here the 470 super is
very impressive averaging 83 fps to make
it 20% faster than the original 470 and
26% faster than the 7800 XT moreover it
was just 10% slower than the 470 TI and
8% slower than the 7900 XT then at 4K
we're looking at 46 FPS on average which
is a 28% increase over the 7800 XT and
21% over the standard 4070 it was also
once again just 10% slower than the 4
72i so a great result here for the new
super Marvel Spider-Man remastered using
the very high preset is no challenge for
these newer mid-range to P in gpus the
470 super averaged 184 FPS which is a
19% boost over the 7800 XT and a 16%
uplift from the standard
4070 then at the 4K resolution the
average frame rate does drop off but
we're still looking at a very impressive
103 FPS and that's an 18% increase
increase over the 7800 XT and a similar
16% improvement over the standard 4070
this also meant that the super was just
6% slower than the 4070 TI the last of
his part one results are quite
competitive between the 470 super and
7800 XT though the GeForce GPU did get
the win here offering 6% more
performance at
440p and again this illustrates just how
in need Nvidia were for that 18% Boost
from the standard
4070 jumping up to the 4K resolution
reduced the average frame rate to 46 FPS
and now the 4070 super was just 5%
faster than the 7800 XT though it was a
massive 31% faster than the 4070 which
is more than we' typically expect to see
so it would seem as though the larger L2
cache plays a key role here next up we
have Dying Light 2 and here the 470
super easily beats the 7800 XT by 23%
margin though it does also cost 20% more
so it is worth keeping that in mind
still 108 FPS on average is a great
result and it meant that the new super
variant is just 9% slower than the ti
jumping up to the 4K resolution we see
the margin remains much the same here
it's 20% faster than the 7800 XT as well
as the RTX 470 so previously Nvidia was
offering the same level of performance
as AMD in this title but with a 20%
price premium so it's good to see that
the 4070 super does correct that now our
Starfield results have all been updated
using the latest version of the game and
at 1440p the 470 super was good for 67
FPS on average making it 10% faster than
the 7800 XT and 18% faster than the
standard
4070 now that 10% margin is maintained
at 4K though the 470 super was only good
for 44 FPS on average so you will need
to use upscaling here and thankfully
Starfield does now support
dlss another new game to be added to our
day one reviews is Alan on week 2
testing at 1440p sees the 4070 super
beating the 7800 XT by a 10% margin as
it was just 7% slower than the 470 TI
then at 4K it's still 9% faster than the
radon GPU and exactly 20% faster than
the original 4070 so a really good
result there the second last game tested
is Watchdogs Legion and here the 470
super averaged 152 FPS at 440p making it
10% faster than the 7800x and 18% faster
than the
470 then as we've seen a number of times
now increase in the resolution does see
the 7800 XT close in and now the 470
super is just 5% faster despite trailing
the 470 TI by a mere 7% margin and the
last game we're going to look at is
Hitman 3 and this is a poor title for
AMD as a result the 470 super easily
defeats the 7800 XT delivering 31% more
performance and impressively even a 20
26% boost over the standard
4070 however once we jump up to the 4K
resolution the 7800 XT fares much better
rendering 90 FPS on average making the
470 super just 2% faster an
insignificant margin we're still seeing
a 16% boost over the 4070
though okay so although we didn't go
over the 1080p results I did record the
data so here's a quick look at the 12
game average the 470 super was on
average 10% f faster than the 7800 XT
and 15% faster than the 4070 while it
was just 5% slower than the 4070 tii
jumping up to 1440p we see the results
are now heavily GPU limited so we get a
better idea of how they really compare
here the 470 super is 133% faster than
the 7800 XT and 19% faster than the 4070
so a good step up there it was again
only slightly slow than the ti model
trailing by a 6% margin however ever the
4K resolution remains a bit problematic
for the 4070 super and it's battle with
the radon RX 7800 XT as the radon GPU
fares much better at the higher
resolution and as a result the GeForce
GPU is now just 9% faster which isn't
amazing given that it should cost around
20% more it was still 18% fast in the
4070 as both suffer from the same narrow
192bit wide memory bus now for a quick
look at ra tracing performance and we'll
start with a plague Tower requium here
the 4070 super was good for 97 FPS at
1080p making it a massive 45% faster
than the 7800 XT which averaged just 67
FPS the margins were similar at 440p
here the super was 42% faster than the
7800 XT and just 5% slower than the 470
TI interestingly though it was just 14%
faster than the standard 4070 so
although it crushes the radon
competition it's not world's faster than
the original
4070 rate tracing performance is
competitive in Resident Evil 4 here both
the 7800 XT and 470 super rendered
around 160 FPS and in this example the
470 super was barely any faster than the
4070 that said it does pull ahead at 40
40p though we're still only seeing a 12%
uplift over the original 4070 but more
importantly it's now 16% faster than the
7 800 XT cyberpunk 2077 sees the 470
super delivering 33% more performance
than the 7800 XT at 1080p using the
medium quality rate tracing preset that
said it's not much faster than the
standard 4070 in this example then at
440p it's 12% faster than the standard
4070 and once again 33% faster than the
7800 XT so a good result overall
Spider-Man remas it is CPU Limited at
1080p so there's not much that we can
really take away from the these results
apart from the fact that the 470 super
is 6% faster than the 7800 XT here but I
expect that margin to grow as we
increase the resolution so let's go do
that okay so at 1440p the 4070 super is
now 15% faster than the 7800 XT and even
then the super appears to be CPU limited
so let's quickly take a look at the 4K
data upping the resolution 2 4K does
extend the margin to
24% and now we find the super providing
47 TI light performance which is
impressive to
see fortnite's been a positive rate
tracing title for the Radeon gpus but
here the 470 super is able to pull ahead
of the 7800 XT though only by a narrow
6% margin again it was just 133% faster
than the standard 4070 and 6% slower
than the ti model then at 1440p the 7800
XT and 470 super neck and neck with 60
FPS which is frankly similar to what we
saw from the standard 407
Star Wars Jedi Survivor is another game
that is quite heavily CPU limited with
rate racing enabled at 1080P and as a
result the 470 super is just 15% faster
than the 7800 XT still jumping up to
1440p only increases that margin of 20%
Which is a decent win for the 470 super
but again it should cost around 20% more
now here's a look at the six game
average at 1080P and keep in mind some
of this data was CPU limited on average
the 470 super was 17% faster than the
7800 XT and just 5% faster than the 4070
though it was also just 7% slower than
the 4070 TI at 1440p the margin extends
slightly to 20% and now the super is 9%
faster than the standard 4070 and 8%
slower than the ti model then at 4K the
margin is reduced and now the 470 super
is 18% faster than the 7800 XT of course
if we included games such as Allen wake
2 as an example that would further tip
things in the GeForce gpu's favor but
for this narrow selection of games the
margins aren't as Extreme as you might
expect now when it comes to power
consumption the 4070 super is very good
testing with Hitman 3 shows a pushing
total system usage 32 wats lower than
that of the 7800 XT while delivering 31%
more performance in that example power
efficiency in Spider-Man remaster was
also excellent again consuming 46 wats
less than the 7800 XT while delivering
almost 20% more performance so
incredible stuff there from Nvidia now
it's time for the cost per Frame data
and as you'd expect we're looking at a
solid improvement over the standard 4070
even when accounting for the newly
discounted price of
$550 despite knocking $50 off the 470
the new 4070 super is still able to
reduce the cost per frame by 9%
basically matching the value of the much
cheaper Radeon RX 7700 XT this also
makes the 4070 super by far the best
value 40 series product that said though
it does still cost 6% more per frame
than this 7800 XT but still that is a
good result for NVIDIA as we believe
radon gpus need to cost at least 10%
less before even considering them as an
alternative and we believe this as
Nvidia offers a better set of features
that often provide higher quality you
also get Superior rate tracing
performance and much better power
efficiency so there is a premium
associated with all of that and based on
past polls the vast majority of viewers
agree now if we look at the current
retail pricing for the models that are
currently available on the retail Market
we find a slightly less favorable
matchup for AMD between the 7800 XT and
470 super as the 7800 XT is currently at
least $10 us over MSRP we also end up
with a number of radon 6000 series
products in the mix though Parts such as
the 6700 XT which offer Great Value they
are much slower the 4070 super is right
there though the only GeForce GPU to
drop below a cost of $6 per frame based
on our data and at $600 us it makes it
really difficult to recommend the 7800
XT at $510 us the original 470 though
it's quite poor in terms of value as it
does cost cost 14% more per frame than
the slightly overpriced 7800
XT all right time for a quick look at
the operating behavior of the 4070 super
and we'll start with nvidia's Founders
Edition model when installed inside an
ATX case with a room temperature of 21°
this is how the card ran after an hour
of load we saw a peak Junction
temperature of 66° with a Hotpot
temperature of 78° while the memory also
hit 78° that said the the card could
just be heard over our case fans with a
fan speed of 1700 RPM resulting in an
operating volume of just 35 DB so
certainly not loud but you could just
hear it under these conditions it
managed to average a COR clock frequency
of
2775 MHz and of course the memory was
clocked at
2,625 MHz for a transfer speed of 21 GBS
per second also on hand for testing we
have the Asus dual RTX 470 super which
is a more typical looking entry-level
graphics card it is a dual fan model
with a dual bias but it doesn't use dual
8 Pin PCI power connectors rather a
single 12v High powerered connector will
do Under the exact same test conditions
as the found aition model the Asus juwel
s a peak Junction temperature of just
64° with a Hotpot temperature of
74° and both are cooler than what we saw
with the Fe model that said though the
memory did Peak at 86° which is quite a
bit hotter than the Fe model though with
a lower 1,400 RPM fan speed it was also
quieter at 32 DB as for the operating
clocks the course typically ran at
2,715 MHz so a 2% reduction when
compared to the Fe model though this is
unlikely to really change the results
just seen in our bar graphs now the
reason for the higher than expected
memory temperatures is inart due to the
thick thermal pads which aren't that
efficient to begin with then they're
transferring the Heat to a thin
aluminium spreader and the right Bank of
memory chips doesn't have any direct
cooling above the spreader so it's a
pretty inefficient design all around
still the memory is cooled and
temperatures did remain within safe
margins throughout our testing then
lastly we also have the gigabyte Eagle
OC which is another base model graphics
card this time using a compact triple
fan cooler and this cooler was also
featured on the standard RTX 4070 and
I'm sad to say it was one of the worst
performing models in our 4 4070 Roundup
hitting a peak GPU Hotpot temperature of
73° but with a fan speed of almost 2,000
RPM so as you might expect strapping
that same cooler on an even higher
powered GPU hasn't exactly improved the
results in fact predictably it's worse
The Junction temperature is now hitting
70° which isn't that far off the Hotpot
temperature of the Fe model that's a
problem because it meant that we were
seeing a hotspot temperature of 85° for
the G CPU that's not great and making it
even worse was the horrible 2100 RPM fan
speed making for a very hot and Loud
graphics card at 38 DB the memory
temperatures were reasonable though
peaking at 76° so slightly better than
the Fe model and much better than the
Asus duel we also saw an average
operating frequency of 2,760 MHz for the
cause so similar to that of the Fe model
I should stress though that while the
loudest and hottest of the models tested
here the gigabyte Eagle OC it isn't
crazy loud I think most will find it
easy to live with but that being said
it's an unimpressive model that I
recommend you
avoid okay so I'm pretty happy with the
upgrade nvidia's offering here at the
$600 us price point we're getting about
20% better gaming performance for the
same price pretty hard to argue with
that that said I can't help but feel as
though this is what the RTX 4070 should
have been from the start
at least 20% faster probably should have
cost $500 as well but at this point I'll
take what I can
get had the RTX 4070 landed back in
April of 2023 with 20% better
performance than It ultimately had it
would have not only sold significantly
better than it did but Nvidia probably
wouldn't have required a midcycle
refresh in an effort to try and boost
sales of course this has always been the
plan offer as little as they can get
away with initially allowing them to
provide a decent midcycle refresh to get
Gamers all excited again this achieves
two things for NVIDIA it allows them to
maximize margins while also pushing out
the release cycle for a new generation
to every 2 years but again with a
worthwhile midcycle refresh to avoid
stagnating
sales so we've got the RTX 470 super now
but should you buy it assuming AMD
doesn't make any last minute pricing
adjustments to the radon RX7 800 XT
which I won't be shocked if they do but
I'm not leaving this video until the
last minute to find out then the 4070
super would be Manu goto GPU at this
price range so roughly $500 to $600 us
and the 470 super might cost 90 to $100
more than the 700 XT which it's a
reasonable premium 18 to 20% more but
when accounting for all the additional
rasterization performance that you get
it's a mere 4% increase in cost per
frame or 6% % if AMD is actually able to
hit their own $500 US
MSRP therefore once you factor in the
additional features stuff like better R
tracing performance and much better
power efficiency the 4070 super becomes
a no-brainer for me it's my opinion that
AMD needs to Discount the 7800 XT to
$450 for it to become the more obvious
choice and I do like that the 7800 XT
has 16 GB of vram which I feel should be
the minimum at this price point so while
that's certainly a strength of the radon
GPU it still has a lot of things working
against it and many of those
disadvantages can be realized
today speaking of features you might
have noticed we didn't provide any
upscaling benchmarks and we didn't look
at frame generation and that's because
both of those Technologies really
require their own dedicated content
which we've already done generally
speaking we believe that dlss offers
Superior image quality to that of FSR so
benchmarking video gpus with dlss and
AMD gpus with FSR it's an unfair
comparison this is because while the
performance uplift overall is similar
the bar graphs completely ignore the
fact the image quality can be better
with the Nvidia GPU then we have frame
generation which we believe to be a
frame smoothing technology not a
performance enhancing technology and
therefore it's not fit for use in
Benchmark graphs this applies to both
AMD and nvidia's implementations of the
technology anyway back to the 470 super
if you've been holding out on your
upgrade and you've got around $600 to
spend I think the 470
super it's about as good as things are
going to get for a while that is unless
you know AMD reduces prices which I'd
say they're likely to do but we'll have
to wait and see what they do end up
doing over the next few weeks and uh how
official those price cuts are and if
they're not just attempts to try and
steal nvidia's Thunder with the new
Super Series cuz that's always
disappointing when you see those very
limited time only deals around the
release of a competing product anyway
we'll wait and see we'll do some
follow-up comparisons and look into all
of that stuff but yeah for now we are
done with this one and I'm glad to be
done because bit of a rough week if you
guys can't tell my voice is still not
fully recovered ended up getting the flu
uh when I started doing this review not
sure if that's a sign of something the
last time I got a flu was 4 months ago
and that was when I was reviewing the
7800 XT and Tim had to present that
video uh I was if this was video had to
be filmed the day before or Tim would
have been presenting it cuz I had no
voice yesterday but it's come back today
and I was able to get this done so yeah
it's been a rough week though
benchmarking with the flu not a whole
lot of fun hopefully for the upcoming
4070 TI super and the 4080 super and I
think there's a 7600 XT in there
hopefully I'll be nice and healthy so
I'll get to enjoy those ones that's
pretty much it um we got float plane
patreon you guys know the deal with
those if you want to get stuff like
exclusive access to our Discord server
monthly live streams a t myself behind
the scenes content q& a lot cool stuff
then you check out either one of those
things for a very small uh fee you get
access to some pretty cool perks yeah
above all else thank you very much for
watching I'm your host Steve see you
next
[Music]
time